كان عمى بريطانيا الساخنه رغم موجات
البردي لا نهايه له اضرابات تشل البلاد قد
تدفع ريشوناك ساكنه 10 دون الجديد للحاق
بزملائه اذا ما استمرت
ثلاثه رؤساء للوزراء واربعه وزراء للماليه
وثلاثه وزراء للداخليه في اقل من شهرين
خلال عام 2020
[تصفيق]
كريستيانو رونالدو
هل تتذكرون شوارع لندن المحجوره بسبب
رائحه كورونا خرقوا قوانين الحجر العام هو
من اطاح ببورس جونسون
وحتى الحرب
تين والطعنات جاءت من داخل حزب المحافظين
المنقسمي على نفسه
[موسيقى]
45 يوم فقط لتخرج محرجه من 10 دون بسبب
دخول بريطانيا اسوا ازمه الاقتصاديه في
التاريخ المعاصر اضافه الى انهيار الجنيه
الاسترلي بريطانيا
في 2022 جائت باول رئيس حكومه من جذور
اسيويه
بشان المالي والاقتصادي قد يحمل مفاتيح
الحل ولكن لا يبدو لنذهب في جوله على
الاسواق
مقومات الحياه الاساسيه كالاكل والشرب
ارتفعت اسعارها بشكل جنوني الضرائب
التلتهم الاجور ونسبه التضخم وصلت مستويات
تاريخيه وضعنا لا نتحدث عن فواتير
الكهرباء واسعار الطاقه في بلد يشهد شتاء
قارسا هل هي انعكاسات الحرب الروسيه في
القاره الاوروبيه ام الانقسامات داخل حزب
المحافظين وتنام شعبيه حزب العمال او ربما
هي الازمه الماليه العالميه التي تلحق في
الافق ام هي تبعات خروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي هي كل هذه العوامل واكثر
عام 2022 كان فوضى في بريطانيا